forte mobilisation des buralistes ils
manifestaient aujourd'hui dans toute la
france pour demander un report de
l'interdiction de fumer dans les bars
tabac prévue en janvier 2008
ils réclament aussi de nouvelles
subventions en plus des quelque 150
millions d'euros déjà perçus chaque
année
yvon martinet pour ne pas avoir à
décrocher leur carotte il en déverse des
tonnes
ici à arras une cinquantaine de duras
liste manifestent contre l'interdiction
prochaine de fumer dans les lieux
publics
a lyon encore du bruit les aussi des
ballons et une opération escargot pour
faire passer le message c'est que des
anciens bien souvent ils aiment bien
fumer leur cigarette en vue dans l'heure
qui la ronge leur café alors si vous
leur enlevez ça ils ont quoi après aline
les buralistes ont ressorti les archives
clope au bec pour eux pas question de
renoncer
il est quand même normal que l'on puisse
faire ce qu'on veut en étant proposé
d'administration ou à ce moment là ils
nous disent ils nous disent de ne plus
vendre faut pas oublier que c'est pas
même les femmes qui prend 78% des ventes
liées à la vente du tabac en belgique et
cigarettes sont moins chers les bières
sont moins chers sur plus sauvage et une
fois conduit à ce n'est pas nous tous
nos clients à partir en belgique
au total ils étaient trente mille à
battre le pavé un peu partout en france
tous espère à présent obtenir de
nouvelles subventions et un report de
l'interdiction est tout à l'heure le
ministre de la santé xavier bertrand a
écarté toute idée de report de
l'application de ce décret